let's take a look at tonight's tigers
pitcher jose urania it's a miracle only
gave up two runs since last start
but uh
you couldn't throw a strike with this
fastball or a slider but this guy digs
in he gets the big double play ball when
he needs it jack peterson who has been
red hot 11 for his last 18 here comes
that ball's hit pretty hard right center
field that one towards the gap and it
will touch down but dude will collect it
peterson around second chuck's on his
way to third and he's got a triple john
peterson's second triple of the year
and he continues to be red-hot the first
left-handed bat that aurenya sees today
jumps him two-seam fastball that floats
right over the heart of the strike zone
one down runners at first and third and
it is anthony rizzo to him here's the
old one
rizzo hits one down the line and left
that ball is going to be in there for a
base hit it bounces past the left
fielder down toward the corner one run
is in bryant will race to third and
bryant's gonna score all the way from
first on the double by rizzo cubs lead
two to nothing great base burning a
great read by kb at first base
he gets off the bag far enough to
realize eventually
that grossman is not going to catch this
ball in the air it's just a little
change up away and anthony just pokes
his ball down the line i think it's
going to be very important as the game
progresses for trev to be able to mix in
the off speed pitch for strikes trevor
williams the right-hander working on
robbie grossman grossman turns on one
sends it into the right field corner and
that's going to bounce against the wall
grossman continues his hot hitting
cruises in with a lead off double
probably grossman's gonna have to get a
massage on his legs he's been running a
lot
and telling you it happens first two one
here in the first inning the cubs came
out hot the tigers are answering three
infielders shift to the right against
nomar missouri 2-2 the other way that's
a fair ball grossman's going to score
candelario to third it bounces away from
the left fielder chris bryant no mar
mazzara
has himself an rbi double got those big
arms good job by mazzara look at that
doesn't pull off it just slaps it we saw
that by the cubs tigers trail by a run
here's jonathan scope 2-1 back up the
middle off the glove of williams
candelario's going to score and scope is
safe at first we're tied well brings up
harold castro
and he has done a very good job of
putting a bat on the ball lately hits an
eight of his last 13 games on the ground
to second base
they will twirl and get scope
but the tigers take the lead on the
fielder's choice
3-2 detroit by as a strikeout victim his
first time i believe bryant was given a
base hit
that one line to the base hit into left
field racing over to grab it is grossman
baez
is headed to second and bryant's gonna
stay put there at third so the cubs are
in business javi baez with the double
cubs at second and third with one down
here is rizzo corners even with the
bases
on the ground to the right side
castro throws them out cubs tie the game
as bryant comes in to score rizzo is
knocked in all three let's see if duffy
now can drive in the go ahead run baez
at third
that one rip their ball past the london
can delario in the score is bias
duffy into second and the cubs lead matt
duffy able to rip that one down the line
the slider really doesn't do a whole lot
for uranium duffy liked it just fine he
was good with it taylor norris gets
ready to face the cubs we're in the
fourth inning that brings up tony
walters left-handed batter against the
lefty norris
throws the bat at it and strikes out
cool on that one good breaking pitch
tigers have their first two on here in
the fourth inning trailing four three
and the lineup turns over for robbie
grossman who has a double in the walk
today yes sir he is locked in baby now
the o2
floater to right
dropping and it does drop in front
hayward runners will advance one bag
only now we got the bases loaded looking
for some damage now with the candy man
that one gets by walters
we're tied again i feel like one of
those games where it might take 10.
now tipped into the glove of walters he
struck him out
one down
and it brings up the big man miguel
cabrera the 2-2
on the ground to third
duffy will go to first badu scores
tigers are back in front 5-4
they will take the ball from alec mills
and go to the bullpen for justin steele
jonathan scott likes the lefty hopefully
he likes to see his teammates score a
couple runs on his single the 01
the other way by rizzo into the right
field corner one run will score mazzara
will be held at third jonathan scope is
clutch again
an rbi double to extend the tigers lead
6-4 he is such
a much better hitter when he doesn't try
and pull but you got to have timing and
the cubs have men at the corners with
just one away here in the top half of
the fifth inning and matt duffy do up
duffy swings and hits one in the air to
deep left field going back is grossman
he looks up it's gone
a three run shot for matt duffy and the
cubs retake the lead seven to six over
the tigers here in the fifth o2 pitch
breaking ball right down the middle
again
and duffy deposits this one in the
bullpen and left walks have been an
issue especially in recent years for
winker
in the door
oh man that was a cutter that hit him it
looked like in his left back foot and he
is
hopping around that doesn't look good
man oh man he is really hurting
oh that came off the knee kneecap
and chamber is going to have to come out
of the game
he is walking very
gingerly tigers threatening with two
outs it'll be left-hander rex brother
swinging a mess strike three brother
strikes out castro and the inning is
over bases are loaded with one away
bottom of the seventh inning cubs
clinging to a 7-6 lead
inside corner got him and japara with a
big strikeout and he rings up nico
goodroom now cabrera one more time
nothing for four today it's been real
quiet for cabrera here's the 2-2
back up the middle that's through
a base hit for miguel cabrera and he
delivers the game-tying run we're dead
locked at seven jason hayward at the
plate
this one's playable
haas a diving grab nice play
that's a heck of a play
he's watching the infield there's harold
came a little bit they got to get over
there they got a sprint don't want your
catcher catching this but he did it
great concentration
and now the winning run is in scoring
position but dude got a good jump oh and
two now trying to finish off goodrum
swing and a miss he struck him out
good job by keegan thompson baez goes to
third with only one away matt duffy
coming up
that one line to right base head baez
coming in and the cubs have the lead in
the 10th 8-7
matt duffy delivers he's got five runs
batted in today craig get kimbrell on to
try to finish this off so the tying run
is 90 feet away with one down the
two-two
base hit up the middle mazara comes
through and ties it at eight mazara
delivers we're tied at eight terrific at
bat now jacoby jones will pinch run for
missouri the winning runs at second base
for harold castro and he's due
the other way
it's in front of brian they're going to
wade jones home the throw home is not
there
harold castro walks it off
jones with the head first slide castro
will get to mobs scene at second on a
long day for harold castro what a
terrific win for these tigers